muy bien vamos a hablar del cartílago el
cartílago es en su nivel más básico un
tejido conectivo que podemos encontrar
en todo el cuerpo humano el cartílago es
un tejido extracelular secretada por
células llamadas condrocitos los cuales
se derivan de las mismas células
precursoras del hueso los fibroblastos
los condrocitos producen materiales
fibrosos como el colágeno que es una
proteína fibrosa fuerte y la elastina
que como su nombre lo indica es una
proteína elástica que proporciona el
componente gomoso elástico al cartílago
algo que quiero mencionar rápidamente es
algo con lo que personalmente tuve
problemas durante un tiempo antes de
comprender que era el cartílago
básicamente es como mencioné un tejido
conectivo como el hueso como la grasa y
otros tejidos conectivos que podemos
encontrar en el cuerpo humano el
colágeno por otra parte es uno de los
elementos importantes del cartílago por
lo que yo a veces confundía estos
términos pero
de confundirme al darme cuenta de que el
cartílago se refiere al tipo de tejido y
que el colágeno se refiere al tipo de
proteína que se encuentra en el
cartílago aquí lo importante es recordar
que el colágeno y la elastina que
conforman el cartílago le proporcionan
fuerza y flexibilidad otros puntos clave
para recordar en relación al cartílago
es que no está in erba do es decir que
no tiene células nerviosas y también que
es vascular que quiere decir que no
tiene estructuras vasculares que pasen
por él es decir que no tiene venas o
arterias o vasos sanguíneos que pasen
por él en su lugar el cartílago recibe
nutrientes y protección inmune de los
fluidos que lo rodean encontramos tres
tipos importantes de cartílagos en el
cuerpo humano el primer tipo se conoce
como 'la y no podemos encontrar
cartílago hialino en la laringe en la
tráquea en la garganta y también en
todas las articulaciones donde las
superficies de los huesos se articulan
entre sí
que éste se llama cartílago articular y
el propósito principal del cartílago y
ali no es reducir la fricción y absorber
los golpes o impactos el segundo tipo de
cartílago que encontramos en el cuerpo
humano es el cartílago elástico que
podemos encontrar en la estructura del
oído externo y también en la epiglotis
que es la estructura que protege la vía
respiratoria cada vez que de glu timos
algo el propósito principal del
cartílago elástico es dar forma y
soporte finalmente tenemos el cartílago
fibroso que lo podemos encontrar en los
discos intervertebrales de la columna
vertebral y también en un área de la
pelvis llamada sínfisis púbica que es
donde se unen las dos mitades del hueso
pélvico y forman una articulación ahí el
propósito principal del cartílago
fibroso es dar rigidez y absorber los
impactos que se transmiten entre estas
articulaciones